you track the travel on the road things
so such a you get a view of the country
that if you really stop and think about
it like how many different places you've
been and your your understanding of
America like you've been everywhere
you've been all all the different spots
get a chance okay this is how they rock
it over here all right this is how they
do it in Detroit
this is how they our New Orleans is
different Oh Connecticut's a little
different and then you put it all
together you get America but if you're
just like a dude who just like parks it
in Columbus Ohio and [ __ ] that's that
and all you know is CNN and TMZ hock
this is what this is what the country's
coming Libs these [ __ ] libs with their
[ __ ] new rules yeah it's not when you
when you're out amongst people no one
really gives a [ __ ] no one gives a [ __ ]
you know it's it's barred chat or at
best but it's you never run into people
that are actually affected you know you
don't unless you're looking for it yeah
you know most of the time it's a
non-issue but it's the most most
pressing issue because it can shift the
country one way or another that's what's
weird about it you no one gives a [ __ ]
about the things that actually affect
them locally yeah the thing that sets
that guy off to [ __ ] about Trump or
[ __ ] about Hillary is he forgot to move
his car on street sweeping day but he
never goes down to petition City Council
about hey this is [ __ ] up that stop
sign was obscured your honor and I
wouldn't have run the stop sign but
there's a [ __ ] branch in front of it
and you need to cut that down and I get
a ticket and I can't afford the ticket
and it's the economy
[ __ ] Trump for whatever like they
just bring it to the highest level well
one of the things that I've realized by
talking to people that really understand
how things work like economics like talk
to Peter Schiff yesterday the economists
he won yeah hit him on my podcast really
interesting guy no no I
he said fun guy he liked you you could
talk to him never drunk in Bisbee he
would get drunk yeah no he he's a really
smart guy I mean he's a very successful
guy but he's right there he's right
there
like when I talk to him like I first
time we did a show we got drunk we just
have a couple of drinks in lighten up
cuz he was doing this like Fox News CNN
thing they do where they have these
five-minute panels we just have to
rattle off statistics you got to tell
the people the problem is in economics
the problem is that like he's a wizard
that [ __ ]
we got to calm him down my two were here
for a long time and so let's get a drink
head of little Jack Daniels then he
loosened up but he set up a video that
said I'm the 1% ask me ask me anything
is that what he said something like that
something like so I went to Occupy Wall
Street and set up a thing it's just
talking to people about economics like
no no this is how you think it works
this is how it really works
but this is what I realize talking to
people like that there's no [ __ ] way
you could be on the ball with all this
stuff with Congress and the Senate and
all the stuff that goes on behind the
scenes and the lobbyists you would have
to be fully immersed in it you would
have to be fully immersed in it and then
fully immersed in the stock market to
have any kind of an argument one way or
another and most people are just having
these half-assed half-cocked shitty
thought-out arguments about almost
everything they talked about including
me
but this is something that we it's
standard there's too much [ __ ] to know
there's too much [ __ ] when it comes
to like politics like you pretend you
understand politics like how long
they've been trying to unravel this
Russia thing again you're tuned out
completely I know I don't know and I
don't care enough to try to learn I get
to a place I went through a period of
you know like back in our conspiracy
theory days then I learned a little bit
but anything that's I really don't know
how government works it's so hard to
know it's so hard to know if I mean just
elementary school [ __ ] you know that
then you know I'm just a bill on Capitol
Hill I still don't even know what that
[ __ ] meant I was gonna stop talking
we pay attention to it more than most
people most was for a minute yeah well
most people the the President or anybody
just represents what they like like I
like a nice guy
I like a no-bullshit guy
okay and then you just find whoever's
best fits that mold and you support the
president yeah who's the most popular
yeah it's fascinating though i yeah i
think if Trump was any Republican that
wasn't a [ __ ] [ __ ] but stood for
the same principles there would be no
outrage they hate his personality first
which I'm not against you yeah yeah he's
a [ __ ] loser but he's the one you
created we were just talking about and I
mention it on stage here and again that
Trump makes me happy sometimes in that
he's a product of everything like what's
that levy on ball that [ __ ] like
basketball dad oh yeah he's famous just
cuz he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and he knows
hey if I keep being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the more I'm gonna get noticed and Ann
Coulter who just says or Tom Leykis or
the Nuge we were just talking about yet
the new job people say outrageous things
just to get attention I'm 40 when I said
I feed the trolls and then all of a
sudden you elect a troll so [ __ ] you
it's all you people that watch TMZ and
[ __ ] buy a tabloid because [ __ ]
so-and-so said something outrageous
again